good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I
am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2022 2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture series
is supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through grants
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has been focusing
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to differing
themes in the biomedical and Health Sciences this
year's theme is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic where each
Friday we enjoy presentations from leading
thinkers about the issues the promises the
opportunities and the hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health effects of
covet 19. these include delayed Health checkups
delayed treatments Mental Health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
participants selected for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will leverage these
presentations as vital material in our culminating
in-person Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June of 2023. today I am delighted
to welcome our speaker Dr Mike Famulare Senior
research manager and head of the Epi team at The
Institute for disease model which is an Institute
within within Global Health at the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation Mike is a core discipline
is using mathematical modeling to study infectious
disease transmission and to improve the utility
of disease surveillance data since joining IDM in
2012 he has been working closely with Partners
in the global polio eradication initiative to
assess the impacts of polio vaccination policies
he is also a co-founding principal investigator
of the Seattle flu study and Innovative
collaborative and in-home multi-pathogens
self-testing that identified the first case
of community transmission of covid-19 in the
United States in 2020 and 2021 he co-led idm's
covid-19 response with a focus on analytics and
modeling to inform code 19 control strategies in
collaboration with the Washington State Department
of Health and with Governor Inslee in Washington
state his current teams and personal research
are focused mostly on pathogen environmental
surveillance phylogenic and in inference methods
evolutionary epidemiology of the polio virus
and immunological modeling and transmission in
epidemiology in continuing with the 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series theme
Mike's lecture today is entitled choices give
meaning to uncertainty stories from pandemic
emergence policy advising and a very personalized
medicine in his talk Mike is going to discuss
these issues in the context of his work on
pandemic emergence policy advising and as a
person living with multiple sclerosis forced to
navigate the trade-offs in covet prevention and
Ms care as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you for joining us also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and alumni are
encouraged to submit any questions they have for
Mike via the chat feature in their Zoom sessions
I'll synthesize these questions and ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome Mike we
are really excited to hear about your work your
progress and your personal story thank you Mike
thank you um thank you for that excellent
introduction um yeah so before diving in I just
want to tell you a little bit about our Research
Institute because we're somewhat unique in the
global Health landscape so I'm in a place called
The Institute for disease modeling which as of
the summer of 2020 is a research institute within
the bill and Linda Gates Foundation uh prior to
that we were in a global good uh philanthropic
investment fund over at intellectual Ventures
um and when the covet pandemic started I wasn't
yet in the Gates Foundation but I was still at IBM
um our mission is to shape Global efforts to
eradicate infectious disease and to achieve
permanent improvements in health for those most in
need um it's a multi-disciplinary team of about 90
people we have a core of research scientists
software Engineers there's technical writing
project management admin I.T you know the whole
um body of work to for technical work together
um as I mentioned we're now an embedded Research
Institute within bmgf we support researchers and
policy makers in global health and part of
our mission is to develop computational tools
to support that while we're part of the bill
Melinda Gates Foundation Institute for disease
modeling is not a funder we are a research partner
you can think of this as intramural research
um we work with a wide ecosystem of Partners it's
universities other ngos government Ministries
research Public Health institutions and partner
with the grant making divisions of bmgf in certain
ways um also just to call out for those of you
who have postdocs or students looking to graduate
we are just now opening a few new roles in
mathematical modeling the first one in environment
in enteric disease modeling is up as of a week
ago over the next month or two or three there'll
probably be three ish more so yeah keep an eye
out on that and let us know if you're interested
um because I'm bad at doing acknowledgments at the
end because the momentum carries me away I wanted
to highlight a small selection of people that
were very close to some of the stories we'll talk
about today um on the left are colleagues from
Mostly Institute for disease modeling and Bill
Linda Gates Foundation um and on the right are
many of our external Partners both in government
um and and in academic research um you know some
folks you might have heard of like Trevor Bedford
Governor Inslee um but also you know many other
folks as well um you know I'm gonna tell stories
today from a fairly personal perspective in the
context of science because I I one is I I want to
share that part of the process and how the doing
of science is affected by how I how I think about
the doing of Science and you know for folks that
are trying to develop their careers right now and
pick their Direction I want to you know model
something that I don't see talked about enough
and that I value um here and so but whenever I
say I I'm almost always with talking about a weed
um so yeah so with that in mind what's this talk
about um the teaser from Gianna was a lectures
could be on any topic you prefer that's related to
the secondary consequences of covid-19 pandemic or
the data science's challenges associated with it
um as I mentioned I've taken that to sort of as an
opportunity to give a talk that balances uh some
technical material and what did we do as modelers
um with some of the personal
aspects of doing that work
um you know as in the framing um the
title right really what I want this
talk is about is uncertainty right that is the
the story of the pandemic especially early on
um thinking clearly through uncertainty uh that's
a that's a skill this series there's principles
um there's ways of going about it um importantly
decision making under uncertainty because that was
the key challenge or one of the key challenges
of the pandemic along the way I'm going to be
open about some challenges that I think we
collectively face as individuals that I also
personally have faced and you know I'm going
to be a bit normative about what I think are
our responsibilities of scientists um in a
way that is probably not quite becoming out
of of a person of my age but for which I feel
very strongly and want to use this opportunity
um I hope you know the mindset I'm hoping you can
be in is one enjoy some stories I'm not going to
be terribly detailed technically at least in the
way my brain works um I hope you can enjoy that um
also throughout covid throughout everything
we have people who pose as experts um I am
going to pose as a very confident expert um at
times I you should be evaluating my credibility
um and also thinking about what that would
be like as a colleague and I hope then some
of the reflectiveness of this talk helps you
reflect on your work in relation to society
um in relation to the program that you're
in um so okay more specifically right
um I want to try to put you in my shoes during
three critical periods during the pandemic
um first starting in January you know figuring
out the Dynamics and epidemiology of what was then
2019 out of gold um from there a little bit on
the what I think I came to understand was our work
in in the interaction between science and public
and government of building a shared mental model
um that being a point that I'll
come back to a very important
um and last I take this opportunity to say
something that I don't think we talk about enough
um I had a unique perspective on personalized
medicine as an immunocompromised person
um I have multiple sclerosis I was diagnosed
back in grad school I kept it to myself uh
professionally until the March 1st of 2020 when
I decided to tell my bosses because I did not
know what my life was going to be like during
a pandemic um and have since felt that you know
what people like me got to talk um and so there's
some interesting science in this um and I wanted
to share the interesting science part of that um
where I have the the unique Fortune of having been
both an expert in covid-19 and a person having
to navigate their own care for a complex disease
um I hope this takes away some Illustrated
general principles um and again I hope it prompts
reflection um and to be clear I'm expressing my
own opinions from my own experience uh nothing
I'll say today is an official position of the bill
Monday Gates Foundation right so it's January 2020
and you read the news strange pneumonia out of
Wuhan right so this is the situation I want you
to sort of put your imagination into um you know
you like me you want to know what's happening and
what's going to happen right why first foremost
you know we're compelled as scientists something
uh you appears to be unique serious and
real is happening in our domain of expertise
um and that is you know of of deep motivation
um just intrinsically for me um and in my case
also my work is related I was working in pandemic
preparedness before this happened I was co-pi of
uh what at the time was the largest respiratory
surveillance study in the country uh with the
Seattle flu study we had started in uh 2018 to
develop uh a integrated testing data analysis
multi-pathogen surveillance platform in the
Seattle metro area coupled with hospitals and
you know at home testing where you got a swab sent
to your house and a courier brought it back in a
day and a half later you had a result if you
were positive for something all that started
in November of 2018. um and so we were trying
we were trying to demonstrate what could you do
with the infrastructure available in the United
States if you had the funding of a Bill Gates
to support where the funding wasn't the problem
but all the problems were going to be how do you
wire that up in this environment um you know
so that was of course professional interest
so but beyond that though for all of us you know
things I want to highlight is like an important
question is like there's something compelling
happen but like are we capable of helping and
I honestly think that's a question that I'm not
nearly enough people ask themselves um as well you
know as we see later you know do you have relevant
research program right you have the expertise
um something else that I thought was really
important and I saw lots of different behavior
um do you want to help any way you can when
something like this happens including me in
the other metaphorical equivalent of filling
sandbags like maybe you don't get to be the
expert right now but there's something you can
do you're good at plumbing and data science or
you're willing to write a report even though you
wish you were giving the TV talk whatever like
you know did you is that where you were okay
with entering that's a choice alternatively
like you have a thing you love to do you have a
thing you're really good at you know do you want
to find your niche in this now disrupted
ecosystem that's also a very valid Choice
um people made that choice well um but it's
a different way of Engagement when you have
different expectations for what you're going
to be involved with um as I mentioned before
you know you got to do the work um pontificating
because you read some abstracts is not good enough
um are you going to do the grunt work of
knowing the thing um before opening your mouth
um related living with scientific discomfort um
living with the risk of being wrong I'll just say
for me that was a huge change I The Institute for
disease modeling we often partner in you know in
a relatively Silent Way in the past um would work
with I would have a small role with a couple who
committees that serve the global poly eradication
program and you know write a handful of papers and
mostly internal PowerPoints that go into decision
making meetings and you know quite invisible
um but all of a sudden finding yourself in the
position to have to speak in a very public way
um was a huge transition emotionally um of course
also important is can you pay for it you want
to Pivot can we pay for it uh the question I
think to ask as you're building a career now
is you know how do you position yourself so that
that's easier if you want to do this kind of work
um I was fortunate to have a very flexible funding
model in my Institute we have hard salaries we're
not closely tied to Grants um so I trusted
to Pivot based on my judgment uh not everyone
has that privilege um other labs their work was
closer to this they were able to Pivot and there
were other gloves that pivoted even though they
couldn't pay for it um hope the best would happen
and some that you know people I know personally
that could have done very good work that could not
support their lab if they made a significant pivot
and had to accept that um and the last point that
I don't think enough people talked about is you
know why you why are you really doing this um you
know it's you know you want to help or you're just
afraid of missing out and you want to have a stage
um so you know from that big picture I want to
give you a feel of what it was actually like
um in the English speaking World
starting right around January 1st 2020.
um you know but yeah I will I think on like the
Saturday after New Year's after New Year's I
opened up my Feedly and read some of the flu blog
community and you know saw a strange pneumonia in
Wuhan and was like you know came back to work on
a Monday and kept reading and by the middle of
that first week of January it was like uh [__]
um there's something there's something happening
um very quickly other people did this and there
was this remarkable thing that I have not seen
the story told very well from this early um where
a small but dedicated group of volunteers created
data out of news um they created analyzable data
out of social media posts um you know and there
were these lineless efforts there was probably I
think three or four of them one of which turned
into Johns Hopkins effort um another you know also
inspired the um U.S covet tracking project that
came out of the Atlantic but you know people were
taking either they were Native Mandarin readers
or using Google translate taking official
you know reports from official social media
mouthpieces on mostly on weibo of case reports
that were often quite detailed in the beginning
um putting that into open Google spreadsheets
that I had a bunch of information symptom onset
hospitalization was there a known exposure you
know Travelers that had been to Wuhan and left
had an exposure window that you could actually
use to help understand the infection progression
um this was an enormously useful resource um you
know an enorm and this was example of something
that people just did um it filled a massive
hole in global Public Health infrastructure um
and enabled people like me sitting in the comfort
of my home in the Seattle area to start not just
reading what was happening but start engaging with
it as a scientist engaging with it specifically
as a mathematical modeler of infectious disease
we had a whole bunch of things he wanted to know
about this disease and and just a quote from I
think early February that I got permission share
for my memory of a colleague of mine davidpiggett
at UW um you know once the case numbers were
bigger this was now International the effort that
he was part of you know he goes I spent last night
watching shit's creek and adding 10 000 cases
to the line list like that was what that became
um and why this is so important is it enabled
people like myself to know to learn about the
disease very quickly and in fact often honestly
a week before leaving the fastest papers came out
um so I'm showing here just a whiteboard
figure from January 29th of 2020. um you
can see my sort of portly frame shadowed in the
middle of it I took a picture after this meeting
um where I sketched out our best guess on what was
the entire acute disease course of of covet 19.
um that was mostly informed by the line list and
a couple of papers that had come out you know we
knew things like that the latent period before
you would start shedding virus was you know two
to five days um you shed probably for seven to
twenty one more you were infectiousness for a big
peak of that was stuff that we could guess from
either exposure data or knowing other viruses
um in analogy with other viruses we could guess
the shape of what the viral titer must have looked
like before there was not a single measurement um
just under the assumption oh wait this is probably
working like a transmission like a flu virus
just longer um oh it's not looking like SARS one
which had a different shape because we're seeing
evidence of transmission from people who are not
very sick um mapping that onto the symptomatic
course in the bottom the blue incubation period
um the acute symptomatic versus severe one of the
things that was really obvious reading the case
reports yourself was when people talked about
symptomatic you know coveted back then they
were talking about two things and you could see it
there was they were talking about you got a fever
um cough and then they're also talking about
you're about to die and you went to the hospital
um and so from that you could parse that you know
that two that four to fourteen days estimate was
often clouding two different things and parsing
it apart helped you understand the progression
um also importantly and I've drawn on this figure
is the transition from incubation of symptoms to
acute symptoms with the first Blue Bar I've
drawn about a day after what I thought was
the rapid rise in viral titer um that was a guess
because by January it was all pretty clear that
there was pre or asymptomatic transmission from
a handful of case reports there was a reports
of a restaurant in Wuhan there were a couple of
Japanese tour bus drivers who got sick from you
know people on the bus um despite being you know
behind a glass partition um and so this was known
um and I want you to reflect on what came later um
so many people who did not know because they did
not do the work early enough and in March they
were talking about stuff that they didn't know
um from the line list uh we you know could
also understand a lot of case fatality even
just from the early cases um this is showing
data from I don't know this is probably if I
remember correctly like a hundred and maybe 100
cases the first from January 15th and earlier
um already clear was the age gradient
in severity um you know already clear
was you had to deal with strong right
censoring as you were watching the outcomes
um you know it took three weeks from when you
first got infected on average to when people died
um and you needed to account for
that to understand the severity
um and I will say that yeah this is when
we started doing work in public at least
through GitHub um realizing that it didn't if
you didn't write it down and put it somewhere
um it didn't exist and it mattered that it
was somewhere for some people can read it
um you know other things that I want to highlight
are how do we learn about incidents you know there
was not a prevalence there was not a lot of
testing most testing was based on X-rays of
lung symptoms was very incomplete beta um but
people are doing really interesting stuff with
opportunistic sampling um there were no
a handful of papers this is a grab from
one of you know in the case of international
travel we saw the Wuhan repatriation flights
um these are after the Wuhan uh lockdown
started you know was starting on January 23rd
um people you know governments were flying out
their citizens um and then testing uh people
who on those planes and from those planes we got
prevalence estimates of approximately one percent
um those were consistent with other estimates that
had been done um from domestic travel within China
um by a group from Hong Kong University that was
the first to publish on this um and so we started
to get a picture of like what at the end of
January there was one-ish percent prevalence and
so with 100 prevalence and an understanding of the
exponential growth we could work our way backwards
um other things that are interesting you know
this was work from the mobs lab Alex vespiani
and so on and I'm showing a snapshot but there
was once a website that was updating this every
day I'm just again looking at the Flight
Network and coloring by was a case detected
um something we were able to see here is that the
cases were showing up pretty much in proportion
to how many flights were leaving China um and
you could watch the cases accumulate and land
be found first in the countries with the most
travel um and so again you got a picture of of um
what was happening what's really interesting about
this is these Flight Network modeling approaches
they're often terrible like quantitatively
they're often poorly predictive
um the Ebola outbreak had a number of massive
Prat Falls by people assuming well-mixed modeling
um that had no validity because Ebola is a
highly socially contact driven disease you
know close contact with acutely ill people
and they're they're on you know their their
um and funerals um but seeing the simplest models
you know the front of the epidemiological modeling
textbook work over and over again for measurements
out of Wuhan was the kind of thing that we often
don't think about how to model but it's actually
really important um if the simplest well-mixing
models are working well that tells you the
virus is at this point in the epidemic early on
doesn't care a lot about social structure um it's
not entrenched in specific behavioral patterns
um it's kind of confined just about anybody um
and that means that the transmission must be easy
for the virus right again it's not SARS one it's
not Ebola it also must be hard for people to see
right they must not it must not just be acutely
ill people because acute people are not getting
on planes very at high frequency in proportion
to normal travel patterns um so seeing this
population Randomness work around the world also
gave us a lot of picture about a a disease that
could easily transmit for which people you know
were not acutely aware that they were infecting
other people and that was clear as the most
likely thing before even the first unambiguous
reports of of asymptomatic transmission that
came out you know a week after what I'm talking
about here was available um and so working
backwards with prevalence and and case fatality
um understanding of the disease course the delays
you know three groups of us uh independently
myself one of them were able to produce the first
credible estimates of the infection fatality rate
um it came out between like point
three and one percent for China
um interesting thing about that point three is the
lowest end number was mine and I actually had an
arithmetic mistake that Neil Ferguson caught and
we updated it it was closer to one percent but I
am telling you what was reported as of exactly
the day that this report from who was made
um that your but the age structure we already were
able to think through things like regardless if
infection goes unchecked Italy the second oldest
country on Earth was going to have a hard time
um Japan first oldest country on Earth would have
had a hard time except for they were very good on
infection control from very early on in contrast
a lot of the conversation about is there covet
in sub-Saharan Africa what does that look like um
severe disease fundamentally important but early
on there was like oh the all sorts of weird stuff
like people don't get it here but it was like we
knew they would have a lower mortality rate it's
much younger age pyramid and that was all clear
from the Chinese data that held up since and so
I just want to leave you for a moment with this
um this was a figure I prepared um this is the
February 19th version um it takes the cdc's flu
pandemic ranking system that they had published
I think right after like in 2010 and draws what
we expect for kova 19 on it um this is based
on infection fatality rate it's based on the
transmissibility um and I think why I wanted to
share this is because we all know what came after
um we knew what this was going to be any
person in March 2020 or later who talked
of uncertainty about the fatality rate who
talked enormous uncertainty about how many
people would get infected if we do nothing
maybe it'll just go away modelers who put
out models where things peaked in April
and deterministically disappeared in June
um all of that was incompatible with what was
known and published by February of 2020. so
every platform person who was talking with less
confidence than I am right now was under informed
and as a field and as a discipline
that's something I still think about
yeah so I kind of want to have an interlude here
on this sort of thinking about what's going on
behind this cloud of stuff right you know I often
think about systems thinking and I've cribbed
these points from the intro to systems thinking
report from the UK government Science office
um systems thinking is a way of exploring and
develop effective action by looking at Connected
holes rather than separate parts you're looking
back on that theme of the slides I just showed you
those were each pieces of uh many variables that
go on understanding a disease that work together
to understand the whole almost nothing I talked
about was a representative sample of anything
um most of it barely qualified as a data set in
a traditional sense but there was an enormous
amount of evidence and that evidence through
mathematical thinking about how do infectious
disease systems interact could allow you to get
an accurate picture and again the the citations
hold up this isn't retrospective we have
we have the evidence not just me the other
people who had done this in parallel people
like me around the world the evidence exists
I know you could get it right in the first time
that requires thinking about context and beliefs
right it's how do people think of the system
because you're going to interact with people
um what when you say the system how do you define
it with respect to everything else in the universe
um you know it's not a it's not just this aspect
of disease it's not just a clinical lens there's
there's Parts clinical lenses apart there's the
holes the whole thing there's layers of different
scales of Parts everything is connected
everything has feedback loops and on all
those connections Parts holes layers there are
processes dynamical processes that propagate uh
what happens whether it be information infection
Etc through that system um our research programs
are often strongly incentivized to do some part of
a system you become a narrow expert in a deep way
um your your account you're it's you're
good at writing grants to be able to say
like I'm the person who does this I know how to
do this we have all the lab equipment to do this
um very valuable work and that kind of
valuable work feeds the system thinking
but I do think in an emergency situation and I
do know that other talks that's watched in the
series have brought this up before you
do need systems thinkers in key places
um and I think as Leaders um in the future and
think about our careers think about are do we
want to position ourselves as system thinkers if
if so what do we need to do to be actually good at
it not just to be a thinker you know be like and
I actually have the skills conversely if we know
that we're not going to position ourselves that
way because our passion is you know in my case in
an alternate life it's the evolutionary virology
of polio viruses you know if I went to if I left
Global health and went to Academia I would write
weird evolutionary bio papers on a nearly extinct
virus because I love it um okay that's great do
that um I'm asking you at this point you know as
you think about shaping your career relative
to the incentives to to do one type of thing
um how do you want to relate to the systems
around you okay so switching topics for you
know or continuing on the story you know I pose
a provocative question that we did not answer
and I'll tell you how we didn't answer it but it's
March 2020 should Seattle area close schools right
so my study Seattle flu study um we in early
February we had uh worked with Thermo Fisher
um this was not me in some ways I was the least
important of the 11-ish principal investigators um
on the story um but um I worked with Thermo Fisher
to design a sars2s day that we could add on our
um you know Multiplex respiratory disease array
but of course as everyone I think maybe remembers
um no one was allowed to use tests that weren't
developed by CDC at that time so we sat on it for
a few weeks and um by late February the third week
of February we're fully aware of how untenable
this was there were cases popping up all over the
world There Was You Know transmission was starting
to happen you know we're seeing massive outbreaks
in Italy and so we made a decision to start using
our test um despite it not having been approved
um I think you know the thing that I think cut
through the fear um was Michael book um who's a
professor a researcher at the Fred Hutch Cancer
Research Institute just sort of asking like
you know what would a reasonable person think
um if you know we had the information and
that was the clarifying thing and so with
that we found the first evidence of community
Transmission in Washington state and I think
contemporaneous the second you know parallel to
a community transmission identified in California
um there was a you know a student that
was about to go back to high school
um and got the phone call at six in the morning
and and that was that um now at this point in time
you know we know we have Community transmission
you know literally miles from my house and my
organization Institute for disease modeling
we started to Pivot really aggressively to the
to try to understand this disease as an Institute
and build software tools that were better than we
had to do um you know all sorts of different kinds
of modeling to help understand the situation and
help understand what happened I show here that you
know sort of the most prude useful thing we did
um as a model this was our first mathematical
model of the Seattle area um it was published
this is a report we published on March 10th um it
was calibrated to the very little bit of mortality
and case data that we had consistent with what we
knew about the disease from Mostly out of China
um and we were only able to simulate random
mixing we did not have social structure built
into the model that looked like Seattle
at this point in time we were not able to
model schools in a meaningful way um but we
we realized that like this whole thing this
whole game right now is about decision
making collectively in society you know
Wuhan and China had shown us that you could
use physical distancing to reverse the tide
um and so we knew that that was a choice that
could be made and so we made a choice in the rest
of our work on situational awareness in in all
the contexts where we were the ones saying here's
what we think is happening here's what we think
could happen we never showed a forecast we always
showed scenarios with choices because we knew we
were trying to we were talking to people to say
here's what can happen in in your control I think
that's one of the things that was really important
um in understanding of covid and especially in
the beginning is it was in our control and to
be honest it still is in our control and I have
heartbreak about that I won't talk about today
um imagine our surprise when the day after we see
this figure on TV uh behind the governor I'd never
met uh Governor rinsley at this point in time we
had no relationship with the Department of Health
we were just doing this on spec for it helped us
learn and we thought it would be helpful and we
were sharing it with our local contacts in King
County the Seattle area um immediately after that
uh Public Health officials asked us about their
work about the work we had a big phone meeting
with a hundred people who knew a hell of a lot
more about public health in the United States than
I ever did um very stressful this was a um you
have very new and they asked what did the modeling
say and we were like what we could find is if
you know if we can cut at least 75 percent of
the transmission links you'll see prevalence turn
around um you know we had framed it in the context
of one point in terms of like school closures
as an option we did model school closures but we
all we were able to say is we don't know exactly
how much something like that would do um we just
know that they would be very disruptive across
Society because of the way contact patterns work
um we also knew the businesses large businesses
like Microsoft and and um Amazon and Boeing had
already started uh to telling workers to stay home
um and we sort of said we don't know how to tell
you what to do but we know that if you can figure
out how to accomplish this things will go back
um government schools businesses individuals in
the public they may you know shortly after this
they made the decision to close the schools
and transmission as much work um to home as
possible we were this you know by March 6 by March
11th March 12th this was already well underway
um by March 23rd there was a Statewide policy um
we were a week you know ahead of almost everyone
um California was also at the front of the line um
and probably saved a few thousand washingtonians
just this um something really exciting that
started to happen afterwards was by putting the
work out in public um and then government choosing
to put the work out in public even further
um it started this process that I I don't know
how to prove um its value but I believe was
really fundamental to some of what went well here
um was we started people started using our work
as a small piece of their information environment
to build their mental model of what was happening
um this was a blog post from somebody I never met
who starts off with you know there's a plot that's
been stuck in my brain for about 10 days and this
is on March 25th which was our plot and he goes
I'm going to take the data that the Department
of Health is putting out and put it on the plot
and and see if I can figure out what what uh what
reduction in Social distancing have we occur have
we accomplished and you came to a reasonable
conclusion it looked like we were following
the 25 reduction curve at that point in time um
things were still going up well but they hadn't
not going up quite as fast um this was just one
person you know in a small way building their
own picture with the input of us as scientists
um that happened all over the newspapers worked
um with government with us and did a lot of
really good science to say what the science
communication to say this is what people think is
happening again our model is what I'm highlighting
but there were versions of this from the public
health officials from other research groups from
direct from government um you know continuing
to communicate in our communities in our state
as it grew this is what we think is happening um
it wasn't here's what I it wasn't always here's
what I think you should do that was governor
inslee's job here's what we're going to do
um but it was often just what is happening it
was situational awareness over and over again
um you know seeing it by March you know or by
the second week you know third week of March
that things hadn't turned around yet a stronger
stay home order was issued and that bent the peak
in western Washington um and again and this is
our model based estimates of prevalence um and
we probably never hit one percent prevalence which
was to say what Wuhan hit that I was talking about
um you know two months earlier um and our
modeling I think was a small piece of that and
um yeah and so I just want to highlight the roles
right in this because this first month which we
were learning as we go building on a career
in public health engagement and Global Health
engagement around the world but never at this
pace and never at this level of of stakeholder
visibility you know media government public you
know there was the scale of it was totally new
um you know we recognized that we needed our team
collectively to stay up to date on the Sciences as
much as possible on having a team at one point was
part-time 30 people around 10 people every day was
a huge part of that um that we were incorporating
in the models you know mental models at the top
scale how does the world work in a way that I can
engage with that you can engage with but then also
computational because the computational models put
the discipline in the mental model you can't have
one without the other um computational models that
aren't serving some broader understanding are just
you know they're playing with computer conversely
trying to build a mental model that doesn't have
any mathematical rubber meets the road pressure
is how you get opinions that are not that don't
make sense mechanistically or how you start how
you continue to believe something it's no longer
possibly true if you've been engaging with the
data um we were trying to serve ourselves as
scientists you know my institute's focus is
global Health not domestic health and so we
ended up because you know this was an emergency
and all hands on deck we ended up doing a lot of
work locally but that was always in part to serve
understanding how we could help people globally in
places where the data were not so rich and the
relationship's not so strong um part of it was
we all you know we always shared uncertainty and
tried to talk about what that meant um we always
enumerated multiple options for the future
as I said because we're always emphasizing it
was a choice nothing was predestined nothing was
guaranteed to occur you got to pick your adventure
um and you know we would carefully express our
opinions whether when we were requested or when
it was part of an ongoing relationship but we
tried hard to not push for personal preferences
um another thing that's really important is it
was really clear with our partners and the way
we talked in to everybody that we interacted with
researchers media government our families we're
learning together as we go there was no false
certainty there was no this is how it works there
was no you know it was here's what we understand
today and again making everything as public as
possible and I've listed a lot of our roles but
actually our partner's roles are in some sense
much larger and and simpler to list we were a
piece of input we were part of a relationship
Network I don't even know how many other inputs
went into how many other people I don't know you
know when we when we worked with Governor inslee's
office over the next 18 months I have no idea the
the many other organizations which ones had what
Leverage What what meetings had what you know we
were just like here's what we think is going on
scientifically let's keep the front edge alive
they take that they take what they value whether
it be someone reading the newspaper someone
reading our report or Twitter um someone making
decisions for eight million people whatever they
else they value whatever other inputs they get
and they are the ones who have the decision to act
um they are the ones who act as they see fit um
it's our place to help inform it's our place to
honestly communicate when asked what we think
we would do um but we have to trust that we
don't know we can't model everything um I don't
know if I'm right about everything and there
are lots of choices where I think I would have
probably made them differently where the outcome
was better than what I would have made um and so
it was really really good to know and so I just
want to leave again I I'm taking way too much
credit because I'm just talking about my story
um but despite having the first outbreak in the
country um Washington State today was 46 per
capita in total deaths um in the United States and
so not only did things go right at the beginning
but a lot of things stayed right um relative to
other places um they could have gone more right
um but a lot of things went okay and I think that
the shared mental model um part that happened
a tiny way that we contributed and just the
ecosystem here built I think was a big part of it
um yeah and so this is something again
this is you know data science and analytics
um you know I I really have been come to
understand that this is the point this is the
point of being a mathematical modeler is to help
people build mental models help myself do that
um right computational modeling is essential
for disciplining those models it's essential
for making them specific mechanistic for learning
how the system actually works right you have to
the computational model is incredibly valuable
there but it's it's niche just specifically that
um we have to understand there's a small domain
of things we can ever model um computationally
explicitly and those are going to interface
with things that we don't have the expertise
for or we cannot quantify and understanding how
to make the handoff from those interfaces is a is
an act of learning that one has to engage in
deliberately if they want to be good at this
um and again good modeling is useful if it helps
people make better decisions right it's not about
a paper it's not about cool code um a lot of the
modeling we did was way simpler mathematically
than we thought it was going to be um there
was different or there were different kinds of
innovations that weren't like the machismo of
simulating a million people and doing complex
interactions but we're like you know turning um
you know doing inference of our effective into a
deterministic algorithm instead of the stochastic
one so you could run it in the millisecond do it
every day um but most of the the actual Concepts
were quite simple because that's what people
needed turned out you know um and knowing you
can't do everything so you have to hand it off
to others and you have to approach others with
the expectation that you're going to only give
them what you're going to give them and they're
going to run with it you have to trust that
um you know is how I think about the work that
that we did and I think about it going forward how
we will continue to do it to the one of my best of
my abilities all right so there's one more theme
um kind of build a very different scale of the
system um I wanted to talk to this audience
about my personal experience as somebody living
with multiple sclerosis during uh this pandemic
um you know March 15 2020 I have a picture I took
of myself um this was a point in time where we
were being told masks are either not effective
or if you have them we have to save the n95s
for the healthcare workers and I was some maybe
one percent of my grocery store at this point in
time was wearing a mask and I felt um I had to
explain myself because it was such a socially
um disruptive feeling um and so yeah there's me
with an immuno compromise on my shirt so I can go
to Trader Joe's and feel like I'm not going to get
harassed um moving forward um you know I a very
scientifically interesting problem that also is
personally very relevant I think the two together
means I probably overthought the hell out of this
and you will enjoy possibly thinking about that
um so the treatment that I use for multiple
sclerosis the one of the more effective ones
or more effective families are are B cell
depleting therapies they they eradicate most
of your B cells which are the antibody producing
cells um and that reduces the um progression of Ms
because Ms is mediated we now know by Epstein-Barr
virus which as an aside Ms is long Epstein-Barr
um so something to think about a chronic
disease arising from viral infection
um but regardless of you know compromise this is
known as back then the blunt vaccine responses but
it was not we never had a novel antigen people
get an ass as adults you've had you've seen flu
before you've seen RSV before you see you know and
so we knew blunt did but we didn't know how zero
um but you know we're probably at higher
risk of severe covid-19 but by February
21 it was clear that it was not a lot
higher you know factor of two to four
um thankfully not a factor of 30 for if you get
infected you're gonna end up in a hospital you're
dead um but the decision I have to make is undue
for my next treatment which is going to deplete
my B cells again and February 2021 vaccines are
here but I don't yet know when I'll be eligible
um of course the standard of care is the
neurologists think about neurology and the
you know Public Health people think about covid
and never the twain shall meet um they happen to
intersect in my body um professionally I'm up to
date um I will have no data like there's no one
can tell me what the vaccine Effectiveness for
people like me will be um so my choices right
are I can change my treatment um I can try to
get my B cells back at elevated risk for my Ms
um which will last you know if that damage
will some usually only partially recovers
um I can also vaccinate whether my B cells are
depleted or not and see what happens because
we don't necessarily we don't know 100 what's
going to happen right so I have to break down
the problem right I don't have to study so
there's Immunology I'm going to go a little
faster now there's my Ms progression you know so
what can I predict about the vaccine what can I
predict about the interaction of vaccine and
my medicine what can I predict of if I change
my medicine what happens to my Ms um the key
thing for decision making under uncertainty is
what do I value what am I more afraid of what
will I feel stupider about if it goes wrong
um these were things I had to ask um
and then of course my decisions again
um while I'm saying a lot doesn't exist there
was an amazing paper by some real experts in Ms
Immunology that they wrote in 2020 describing
like based on what we understand about the
immune system this is probably how this will
work um it was very helpful for covering not
the emotional parts of these issues not the
values driven parts of these issues but the
um the scientific parts and largely got
it all correct before we had even vaccines
um so if you want to read one on this topic
go look up the baker 2020 paper on uh covet
vaccine Readiness um so yeah we have data
I'm going to skip through this for time
um get to the last Point um the data helped me
make some information I can calculate stuff about
Ms risk I can calculate stuff about covert risk
I'm in the position of living in a place where we
have good estimates of covet prevalence because my
team is making them um but it comes down to I the
decision I decide may my fears are you know so is
Ms going to put me in the hospital or is covered
going to put me in the hospital giveaway I know
of my exposure and the data on litter trim both
diseases you know uncertainty is huge these
are calculations of multiplied relative risks
um would you believe they came out within
a factor of two they were exactly the same
um that meant if the decision was entirely
about what I valued hope for and fear
um and that's actually I think why I wanted
to tell this story because so much of decision
making under uncertainty is exactly about that um
and there's the interlude right there's rarely an
answer or rather there's often no answer to the
question you wish was the right one to ask like I
wanted something to tell me you should delay your
vaccine and do your medicine today or you should
do your medicine delay your medicine and do your
vaccine as soon as you can whatever the answer
could have came out that way but it didn't right
and that's the thing like there are easy decisions
in life there are things where the outcomes are
totally dichotomous and by dichotomous I mean the
uncertainty is small relative to the difference
it's easy to know one versus the other and pick
um this fell into the class of what I
might call a hard easy decision right so
the second type of is the MS one the minor
differences in outcomes it felt like this
decision mattered but given the information
either Choice was was pretty much rational
um there's also a thing that I think a lot of us
got didn't do the way I would have done during the
pandemic um to that effect you have you have a ton
of uncertainty but enormously asymmetric outcomes
these decisions should be easy um the asymmetric
outcome that can happen dominates the risk
um these are places where the adjective we
feel under all that uncertainty is often has
a lot more to do with wanting to be in control
than actually needing more information you know
there are actually hard decisions too you know
you don't have you have an important decisions
outcomes are meaningfully different and you don't
have the evidence there are things called wicked
problems which is a great article Wikipedia look
up that term um it's about things where there
is the answer to the question how do you ask the
question changes the answer the answer changes the
next question people disagree on values and also
just personally overcoming your strong beliefs
um a lot of coveted disagreement was about
these things which are not data disagreements
these are values disagreements it's only
this one that's actually a science problem
um and understanding those um is important so
yeah and so one of the things that we often
took away for our own work and for sharing
with our policy Partners is you know can we
if you have a decision you can't make can you
figure out a different way to ask the question
or a different way to approach how you might do
something that would help the world change so that
you could answer the question you're trying
to avoid hard questions is an important art
um so I will tell you with the last minute
or two that I want to take here before I
open up the questions um you know the decisions
I made I had three rounds of this so I decided I
didn't know when vaccine was coming so I went
with standard of care I got my MS treatment
um I got standard of care um after knowing that
my vaccine didn't work very well I got no antibody
response um the next round I delayed treatment um
I took advantage of lack's record keeping to start
over even though that wasn't the policy it should
be the policy but it wasn't um in my opinion it
should be the policy and so I got better than
standard of care for what I value I got a maximum
possible vaccine response in my Ms held study
um interestingly I developed the Mild Eczema
which is an autoimmune reaction something to think
about um did the same thing again delayed updated
um you know covet exposure risk had
changed a lot Omicron changed things a lot
um you know I don't I got a mad outcome um I got
the best vaccine response but I had a bit of an MS
relapse that's only 80 recovered it's not severe
but that last 20 is probably going to stay with me
the rest of my life and you know by this point in
time I had known how to control my exposure pretty
well and I don't have kids yet um and so I you
know and so I don't know that was the right choice
um I'm Gonna Save the reflections I will leave
a question for you of was it ethical for me a
wealthy white person um working for a
global Health philanthropy that's had
an a complex place in the global vaccine
effort uh Global vaccine Equity landscape
um to take advantage of LAX record keeping and
get some extra doses I have my answer to that
um I think it's a question you
guys might enjoy thinking about
um you know kind of to get to the point here
is this was my personal story that lives in
a very unique place in my personal skill set um
but there are millions of people with this kind
of situation autoimmune diseases in particular um
personalized medicine we often talk about genomics
um this is about risk factor relative risk for
which much of the data that you need to make
these kind of decisions is actually created
by the scientific process um I would love to
see someone some whether it be you know a large
institution or academic program or Pharma to take
on the challenge of not just a drug development
but a drug a a decision-making system development
because there is a approach to randomized clinical
trials of the treatment process that could help
people with doctors say what do you value when
you have these competing risks here's what we
know about the competing risks and the weights
that we would apply to them given your values
here's this here's how you think you can make
a decision um and I bet you we figured out how
we could do that within better than standard of
care both in terms of lower clinical morbidity
and improve patient satisfaction um I think this
is a really fruitful area for the next 30 years
of biomedical data science that is only just
beginning to be poked out in a quantitative way
so to wrap up you know I'll leave you here what
do I hope to leave you with right you know much
of the story was about the intersection between
different kinds of science that we do on the
regular right and as data scientists we often try
to say here's the data I have here's the question
what's the answer within my data um that's alone
is bad often that doesn't give you the right kind
of answer um you know we descend from the natural
philosophers right it's often tempting to think on
you know here's how I think the world Works what
evidence supports my model um that alone is bad
um similarly as human animals right we often say
here's what I think and this is what we should do
those are often prostitutes for
actually I'm avoiding what I feel and
I want us to do this thing I hope will make me
feel differently um my so my Ms decisions will
like that and I think that's very worthy of
love and compassion but if you've motivated
if your motivation really this is about feelings
is why you're so certain is obscure um that's not
a sound basis for Action yet as scientists as as
individuals maintaining a dynamic balance on top
of all of these and other cells That's essential
to doing our job to the best of our ability and
I don't think we talk about it enough and that's
why I took a chance to do this today so thank you
Mike thank you so much you know as you were
talking I was just thinking about some of those
early news reports that were you know coming out
on the national news where it just looked like
Seattle was on fire with covet in those early
days and it this was so worrying and as we were
talking about before we got started I have family
there and in Seattle and so it was like it must
have been absolutely frightening on the one hand
because you're there at you know in The Hot Zone
as it were you're seeing it happen in real time
you have a responsibility as a scientist to be
taking these data and to be you know turning them
into something that's actionable at the same time
you're a person with a particular Health concern
and you must have been absolutely terrified and
I was wondering how in that position you were
able to kind of get that dispassionate kind
of distance between maybe where you're you know
your personal concern to basically put the focus
on the task at hand and to you know Marshal
that you know internal fortitude to be able
to go and do your job how did you manage to do
that because that must have been scary as heck
thank you for asking that question I
almost started crying when you asked it
um the the fully honest and short answer um
I guess there's two there's kind of two parts
to it one is uh something I started unpacking
in therapy starting in April 2020 is you know
I had a you know my family growing up had stuff
that I didn't fully understand that seemed normal
um that worked together such that I'm one of those
people that gets calm when things get stressful um
I I someone who's over it was over trained to try
to solve other people's problems and figure out
what is is going on and how I can help um and so
there was a sense as as like the enormous pressure
was Building inside of me um I was probably
too good to be honest at suppressing everything
um but then the other thing that happened is like
you know something I still reflect on is like you
know in February 24th we hadn't started doing
using the covet tests on the you know hundreds
of respiratory samples a day we were collecting
with the flu study but you know we were I was you
know 99 sure covet was somewhere circulating
in the United States you know the next night
you know we run the first batch of tests and
one out of 400 on the you know our positive
the difference between 99 sore and 100 sure
felt way bigger than I ever thought it would
and the next three weeks um we're the most
Lucid of My Life um all sorts of things I mean
like because everything was the most important
thing it was actually really clear and my mind
was really quiet and it was weird stuff like
my mother-in-law um is a February 29th birthday
and my knowledge of the local epidemic started
on February 26th or 27th I remember correctly
um but the public knowledge hadn't yet um and we
had planned and as a February 29th birthday it was
her 19th leap year birthday as a 76 year old um
and there was a large dinner plan at a restaurant
and I remember thinking I the prevalence
in this area is less than one in a thousand
and there will not be a thousand people at this
restaurant we're not going to cancel this dinner
um knowing that next week we were
going to never go to a restaurant again
um you know and and knowing that in February when
nobody else did um but why bring that up is is it
was really easy to like be present at that dinner
because that was the most important thing for
that five hours um and later that night we got
calls from a New York Times Reporter which I'd
never talked to before because Trevor Bedford
had tweeted out what we thought was happening
um and that was the easiest thing to do because it
was it was scary but it was like my father-in-laws
and that worked for three weeks and as soon
as the team around me really spun up and we
had 30 people working together in the state
that's probably the public health relationships
and the pressure came off a little bit um I had
to move the relax I psychologically tore myself
apart I was a mess I was impossible with um is
like the foot was on the gas but the load had
eased off and the engine was ripping itself
apart and so that's that's the honest answer
it's uh it's an incredible Story one of the things
that um one of our uh listeners was is curious
about about you know now we're kind of on the the
downslope of covid and the emergency declarations
are ending at the state and federal levels and
it's a lot of people who are in positions as
modelers or data scientists working in this space
are either losing interest in this area because
it's not you know hot air not the hot area anymore
um or they're basically they're you know being
made redundant because of the jobs going away
what do you think are some of the best uses of
the modeling time and resources uh during this
what they referred to as a relative peace time
yeah that's a great question it's one
that we're struggling with um where we
our effort at IDM is is down to skeleton crew
and and honestly mine is down to almost zero
um the way that I'm thinking about this long
term is there are lots of different challenges
um I putting the effort into building
relationships with people who make decisions
um building relationships with your public health
colleagues that are on the things that they are
actively caring about being flexible about your
disease expertise um but being you know fairly
being committed to your partnership and decision
making or modeling Niche expertise are the places
that I want us to see us grow as a field because
that's what will be sustainable and that's also
what positions you to be reactive effectively um
we were able to be of reactive effectively because
my Institute was focused on working in Partnership
across Global Health we had a lot of experience
um how and so I how you figure out how to write
that into funding proposals while not losing the
scientific knowledge that's required to Pivot is a
challenge I don't think we've I don't think I know
how to tell you how to solve but it's really it's
it's putting Partnerships ahead of viruses is I
think the more sustainable pathway here right well
Mike I want to thank you so much for sharing your
experience with us um really at just the front
lines of the covid-19 pandemic in our country
kind of watching it happen in real time in those
early days and uh you know kind of developing some
of these models which really spearheaded a lot of
interest in doing this um at this kind of scale um
being in that position doing making models with
limited information and then trying to improve
upon them uh must have been a very exciting but
fraught and emotional time for you personally
and I want to thank you for sharing your story
with us um it's really inspirational so thank
you thank you very much and thank you everyone
for for listening I hope uh you know stuff you
can take away from it to reflect on for yourselves
and I appreciate that to share thank you thank you
Mike and everyone have a wonderful weekend
and we'll see you next week bye-bye now bye